the four lenses
what i'ma help you do with this stream
is i'mma help you shift between
different lenses different ways
to see perceive
experience
this is where the vast majority of
people are stuck
they're only able to wear one lens
in that lenses personhood
think about it if you're talking to
somebody
and all they know how to do is talk
about business
how annoying is it when all they do is
talk about
stocks and money and entrepreneurship
and marketing and sales
and they have no idea about emotional
intelligence
they have no idea about nature about
biology they have no idea about the
kingdom of god
within their own heart and within
everyone's heart
they only know how to wear one lens it's
just a business lens
now what if they were also able to wear
the science
lens and what if they were able to wear
the spirituality lens
now you see where i'm going the more
lenses you can wear the more
of a chameleon you are the more you're
like a jedi
the more you are like joseph in the code
of many colors
the more you have precision
with creating awakening around the
planet
be a jack or a jane of many trades
know how to navigate the entire
possibility space of conversations
and so here when most people are stuck
with wearing the person lens they don't
know how to get out of the person lens
they're stuck in it
very much where i was as well stuck in
being just a person
and it's so fascinating because you're
introduced
to concepts like source aka the big bang
you're introduced to concepts like this
but you never shift your identity to it
so you never actually put on the lens
because you never shift your identity
or for example the universe you're
taught about it but you
never shift your identity to
it so you never actually put on the lens
and then of course the most subtle
because this is the hardest pop this is
the hardest
shift to make in lenses the hardest
shift to make in lenses is from the
person to awareness by far the hardest
because it's right there in front of
your face
this is your awareness
and this is your awareness with an
experience
so here you have an experience of the
four lenses
that's what you're doing with watching
this video now if you
pause the video and lock your screen
what will you have
you will have a blank screen
an unmodulated screen
this is the ultimate reality the
ultimate reality is the blank sheet of
paper
it is the dark locked screen
without any modulations
and then come all of the modulations
here's all this writing on the sheet of
paper you're experiencing
this the four lenses video the
modulations on the screen aka all this
form that appears
the infinite creation has so many
possibilities
all the different possibilities to color
a sheet of paper all of the different
possibilities to modulate
a screen all the different possibilities
to make
form to make these costumes
all of the possibilities of dreams and
civilizations
and explorations
to make this shift from person to
awareness you have to quiet the mind
you have to use the breath
to become aware of awareness itself
very subtly another trick to do is to
train yourself to
perceive from your eyes like your eyes
are big ping-pong
balls and and really focus on perceiving
from your eyes like ping-pong balls
perceiving from your
eyes
and then still yourself
stop thinking about the past and the
future
just be present while looking
with two ping-pong balls and then
roll your ping-pong balls around
into the different corners
and become aware that you are looking
and if you have to hold your eyes open
like this
it really accentuates the process when
you kind of open up your eyes like this
it adds another depth to it and so
now you're rolling your eyes around
and you're calming your mind and you're
staying present
and what's happening is you're slowly
becoming more and more aware of seeing
itself you're becoming aware of
observation of witnessing itself
what was present your whole life but
that you never gave attention to
and then as you do this process you
recognize that
every single other human on this planet
is also
seeing with their eyes
and then what you recognize is that all
of
the power to see the power to know
the power to experience is god
so we are all god and this is all our
creation
so you shift from being a person to
being awareness
this is the biggest shift in lens
you have to know how to become more
subtle
because the person is very
very much like a meat suit
and so you're stuck in this body
and you're perpetuating the idea that i
am in this body i am stuck in a physical
vehicle body on a finite planet that is
also
physical you have to shift
from the physical to what's more subtle
and what's more subtle
than objects
the subject the subject
look at yourself in the mirror just go
to the
mirror and open your eyes like this
and look in the mirror
and look at yourself
and look at the fact that you're looking
at yourself become aware of the fact
that you can see
and observe
and notice how you are looking look
notice how you are
observing you are literally
observing the ability to observe
think about that you when you look at a
mirror
you are observing the ability to
observe so you are aware
of the fact that you're aware
so go to a mirror
and look at the mirror like your life
depends on it
look at the mirror
look at yourself in the mirror
like your life depends on it and keep
looking at yourself
perpetually daily look at yourself keep
looking at yourself keep looking
at the very pupil
in the center of your eye
look at the pupil and wonder might
that very pupil in the center of my eye
be the same observer that is in the
center of everyone else's eye
now you're getting closer to source
so when you get to the pop
from person to awareness that's already
huge again
you're now become
more subtle you've become aware of the
subject you've become aware of what is
formless this is form
subject is formless okay that's already
a big pop
now this next pop is into source
which would be like we were describing
you have to become aware
of what gave birth to you
no you did not come from your mom who
came from her mom who came from her
mom who came from her mom who came from
her mom
just go all the way up the great chain
of being go
all the way to source everything comes
from the same source everything comes
from the same big bang
everything comes from the same
nothingness everything arose from
nothingness and returns
to nothingness
not only the entire creation but every
single appearance
in the creation arises and dissolves
arise and dissolve arise and dissolve
rise and dissolve verizon dissolve
perpetually
rise and dissolve verizon dissolve
just like this sharpie arose dissolved
i turn my head and that dissolves
those go like this
everything is in this very
emptiness arising and passing
just go to the very pupil at the center
of your
eye that's when this big shift is
happening from awareness to source
as you become more and more subtly aware
that awareness itself is shared the same
black hole that is at the center of my
eye is at the center of your eye
and that that is the very black hole
from which we originated from and from
which everything goes back to
and from which the next exploration will
happening and that they've been
happening eternally
and that every single perception thought
sensation
experience arises and then disappears
into
that is what we mean by source so now
you become aware
of the lens of awareness
which is the subject which is way more
subtle than the physical person
so again you can think of this being the
most physical
this is the most downstream the person
is the most downstream and what we're
asking you to do
is to shift your lens of perception
upstream
go all the way to your source if you
don't
take your identity from personhood to
source
you will forever be ignorant
this is the truth about duality this
is the truth about ignorance and
knowledge
avidia nvidia
the way to taste and unite with the
knowledge that's already around your
neck
is to become aware of awareness become
aware of the formless become aware of
the subject itself
become aware that that is shared that is
god
and that it's all the same
source it arises from and goes back to
the same
emptiness
it's the very source the very emptiness
that gives rise to awareness
into realities
so you can go again
this is most downstream this is most
physical and we're asking you to go most
upstream and when you go most upstream
you get to your
source and you recognize that you
your truest nature is the fact that your
identity
is the source that makes awareness
and realities all of this infinite
creation
and so now we'll put on the lens of all
that
is so
one of the core reasons why
the fourth lens is all that is is
because
you have to go all the way to your
source you have to go
all the way upstream to your source
first
and these are the pops that you
experience you go from the physical
contracted identity of a person and you
pop
into the more formless subject of
awareness
popping into it being impersonal
for that being god and then you pop
again into the very fact that i am the
source of
even awareness of even god of even the
shared
witnessing of infinite creation
and then what happens is as you identify
with nothingness
you identify with emptiness you identify
with the very
space of all possible phenomena
so now what is your identity okay i am
the emptiness the spaciousness
of all possible phenomena
okay so that's your truest nature great
so you went
all the way from person to that
and then what do we ask you to do we ask
you to put on
this fourth lens which is all that is
so what we're asking you to do is we're
asking you to put on the lens of seeing
the entire universe at play with itself
so what you did is you
are the source of the universe at play
with itself
so your nature is the source of infinite
creation
and this is one example of your infinite
creation at play with itself
so we're asking you to put on the lens
of all that
is because what happens is when you put
on the lens of all that is
you're no longer the person you become
the entire universe at play with itself
we're asking you to become the way that
god
sees you
stop affiliating yourself with the
person identity
we're asking you to become the entire
universe at play with
itself rather than being your name which
you were
indoctrinated into when you were born
become the very essence of life
itself become the very creationary force
itself
become the big bang in the universe
at play with itself exploring
become aware
of the very same shared observer among
all 8 billion of us that is witnessing
from different perspectives this
beautiful
dreamed creation
and when you put on this lens of all
that is you begin seeing there's no
separation
so you recognize that since we all come
from the same source we all share our
awareness
this is all one intelligence at play
with itself
all that is there's no separation now
the only thing i can do is become a
steward or
a shepherd for the creation awakening to
its true nature
that's what we're asking you to do we
are literally asking you to give your
life
to surrender your life to
becoming a steward and a shepherd for
the awakening of the creation
because then you are serving god you are
serving the creation
and you are not serving your distorted
deluded
contracted personhood identity
and that's why you have to be able to
navigate out of this
lens this is like only
knowing how to talk about business it is
so annoying when somebody only knows how
to talk about business
all they do is talk about marketing all
they do is talk about entrepreneurship
all they do is talk about sales
stocks money they have no idea how to be
emotionally intelligent they have no
idea how to talk about science
how to talk about spirituality
that's what we're asking you to do is
learn how to put on
other lenses get out of personhood and
learn how to put on
the first upgraded lens
of awareness go
upstream to your source
you're intoxicated by the downstream
illusion
of identity with personhood
and with only finity and physicalism
that you have no interest even
in the question who am i
what is my source
might i be god might i be
infinite ask yourself those questions
that is the process of self-inquiry
atma vichara
that very self-inquiry process
will take you to the answer it will take
you to the realizations
of directly experiencing yourself as the
formless
subject of awareness practice these
activities
like the ping-pong ball exercise
and slowing yourself down to becoming
really hyper present
of awareness of the subject of the
witness
of observation
and how it's shared among us
and hold your eyes open like this in the
mirror
as well and take the time to really
analyze
yourself in the mirror become aware that
you are
looking at a creature that has the power
to know
you are looking at the power to know you
are looking
at the power to know when you become
aware that you're looking
at the power to know you become aware of
god
the power to know is god
but you've been brushing off the idea of
the power to know your entire life
you've atrophied the muscle to know
the power to know
because you've been deluded
into only focusing on objects and
experiences
trying to extract peace and happiness
from the creation
rather than investigate who the [ __ ] is
the observer itself
who is the subject itself because the
subject is god
and then you recognize it's the same
subject of awareness in
everybody
and then you stop arguing with god
and you settle into the knowledge
of being infinite
and this just being one of our
exploratory creations
so we're asking you to be able to
navigate across these
lenses and to give up
your person identity
so that you can actually be able to
navigate the lens of awareness
navigate the lens of source navigate the
lens of
all that is stop being
just oriented in one subject
like business it's like the vast
majority of civilization
only knows how to talk about money in
social media
we're asking you to learn how to talk
about consciousness
we're asking you to learn how to talk
about god we're asking you to learn how
to talk about metaphysics
we're asking you to learn how to talk
about nothingness we're asking you to
learn how to talk about emptiness
we're asking you to learn how to talk
about all of this being
the universe playing with itself dancing
with itself
for you to shift your identity to being
life itself
rather than being a person
you have to learn how to shift
between these lenses otherwise you're
going to be stuck here for your whole
life
and you're gonna perpetuate suffering
for yourself and for those near you
and for the world and then you'll get
reborn
liberate yourself from the cycle
of pain and pleasure
by navigating these other lenses of
awareness source and all that
is then throughout your whole life
what will happen is you will feel
peace you will feel joy
you will feel stewardship in service
and shepherding of the creation
awakening
and you won't be stuck in the cycle
of pain and pleasure pain and pleasure
birth and death birth and death
but rather you will know your true
nature as the very source
beyond birth and death that gives rise
to all of this
infinite creation at play with itself
okay that's all these are the four
lenses
learn how to shift yourself out of the
contracted person
identity lens and pick up the subtle
lens of awareness the subject itself
and pick up what is the source of
the subject itself what is the source of
reality itself
become aware of that and become aware of
everything
as one intelligence at play with itself
and serve that one intelligence
navigate between these lenses and win
the game of life
navigate between these lenses and win
the game of
life that is what is meant in the mystic
traditions when people say you have to
die before you die
it means you have to kill the person
before
the person dies before you're 80 years
old and you die
what's going to happen is when you're 20
or 30 years old
or whenever you awaken the person will
die
because you will now become awareness
you will become source you will become
the entire universe at play with itself
you will no longer be a separate finite
person
navigate yourself out of this lens
it's like you're only talking about
money and social media
and we're asking you to learn how to
talk about consciousness
awareness we're asking you to talk learn
how to talk about metaphysics
around god around source nothingness
emptiness
the true nature of reality the universe
at play with itself
and then what will happen is you will no
longer be
as interested in this lens it will
naturally
dissolve the only time you will be
interested in this lens
is when you behave from these lenses
teaching other people of this
lens how to awaken
go all the way to your source go all the
way upstream
know your true nature serve the creation
stop being a contracted person identity
that is arguing
with god and trying to extract peace and
happiness from the creation
learn to navigate between these lenses
infinite adoration thank you
you